so this is green living in a box in film
this in his London hostel last year he
since moved to a different hostel but
his room is much the same size pretty
much it's just reading in a room a
square room for 24 hours a day just
affects you mentally yeah and I know
that it's like this for everyone
everyone they struggling I get that ian
has been diagnosed with bipolar disorder
and he attempted to take his life over
Christmas things had been improving but
then came lock down the hostel has
closed the TV room so the 19 residents
can't congregate leaving them trapped in
their rooms obviously living in a hostel
in a room with nothing today that's not
helping because you just got time to
think and you're just sad and then it's
at the point where you're thinking like
about ten thousand different things all
at the same time you can you know and it
drives you crazy
it literally drives you crazy even in
normal times one in four people
experience a mental health problem every
year and the charity saying warns that
in lockdown conditions more trouble is
brewing our concern is that while the
mental health services are really being
withdrawn a great deal well people are
afraid to access any help because
they're taking the turn away from the
NHS they are going to have untreated
mental illness and with untreated mental
illness we may be facing a backlash an
epidemic of mental illness saying has a
helpline and says there's been a notable
spike relating to domestic abuse that's
also a concern for the help hub a free
service set up by professional
therapists to help deal with problems
created by the coronavirus any mental
health issues that people have I think
will potentially be quite amplified
during this time of isolation and then
obviously we have the inevitable loss
and grief that is becoming more and more
apparent on a daily basis then obviously
you've got the isolation and loneliness
and domestic abuse is also another issue
that's becoming more apparent therapist
yeah it's good
another problem is addiction 28 year old
Ben Robinson is among 75,000 people who
were treated for alcohol addiction in
England last year he's been dry for 500
days but lockdown is the biggest
challenge yet it's a daily battle for me
it's isolation just-just-just brings
thoughts and fears anxiety and worry and
isolation something that we did a lot in
the worst of our days so I drank the
most when I was on my own and so
isolation is simply echoing those
thoughts so what are your mechanisms to
help you get through the day write notes
down so you don't forget what you can
tell other people when you speak to them
because those times are farther apart
now each day I try to find a repetitive
task that might be a jigsaw
it could be restoring antique box that I
just did and you'll find that that does
help by just going to that every couple
of hours it will help Witter through the
day and unfortunately that's how I see
the day's is just getting through them
every day
the Samaritans have launched a study
into the impact of social distancing on
our mental well-being but indicators our
isolation is a real challenge and is
quietly storing up problems in our
communities Jason fair Ascanius